>>Clyneice: I guess the biggest
problem I had was the balance,
trying to get him to do
a little bit of outdoors,
not to get so focused
on doing the technology.
Even if it wasn't a game, he still
wanted to be on the computer,
so he will spend literally twenty
hours, if I let him, on the computer.
So we sorta have a deal where,
after two or three hours,
he's supposed to take
a break, go outside,
walk up and down the
block or something.
And he'd go, "Mom, you know,
I really have this balance.
I got everything covered."
So and I do feel that he has that.
>>Carolyn: Well the
other thing I find too,
that they multitask much
better than I ever did.
Because my daughter could be doing
four or five different things,
all at once, with the noise,
the music, and she's IMing
and she's doing her
homework and she's texting.
>>Clareice: They do research
papers on the internet.
>>Clyneice: Mm-hmm.
>>Clareice: The whole thing where
you get your bibliography, I mean,
you know, certainly dating myself.
>>Go to the library.
>>Clareice: Go to the library, they
don't do research papers nothing
like what we were trained to do.
>>Carolyn: There's an issue
of plagiarism and they have
to be very careful with that.
So I think they step very cautiously
as they do their research and how
to write what they've
read and translate,
analyze and translate
that, and understand it.
So I think it's a little
bit more rigorous.
I mean, we did a lot more
legwork to do our papers, but--
>>Yeah, but I found--
>>Carolyn: Yes.
They have to learn how to sort
and find this information.
>>Clareice: You try to get a balance
between how much are you, you know,
micromanaging their lives?
Especially since they
don't want you there.
You know, when they start hitting
seventeen, but I think as a parent,
you still have to make
sure that you do it,
because the digital
opens the world to them.
It is just so all encompassing
that if you stand back
too far, they'll get lost.
>>Carolyn: Well, my daughter,
she was a little put off
because I friended her on Facebook.
She couldn't say no.
So and it was with some trepidation
that I did it, but I friended her
and some of-- and Ruby and Ellie too.
And there are things that, I kind
of look from the side, you know,
and I don't look directly at it,
because some things
you don't wanna know.
So what I do, once in a while, I go
and I look to see what's going on.
What is she talking about?
Who's she talking to?
And I think they express themselves,
and it's their world and their forum.
And I don't think they
sense any danger,
and I think they feel this
freeness and openness.
>>Sujatha: Even though
they think they're mature
and know what they're doing,
sometimes what they write
and everything on it, it concerns me.
>>Clyneice: I do feel that as
long as you've got some oversight
and you're not allowing them
to be totally kids and get
into dangerous areas, that it's
one of the most wonderful things
for them, because this is the
direction that the world is going in.
>>For more information on what works
in public education
go to edutopia.org